the most coherent candidates on the
Republican side on foreign policy so far
are two one would be Marco Rubio who
absolutely is the most traditional stand
up for intervention indispensable
America supporter he has basically said
that I will defend any intervention of
international you know airspace
cyberspace outer space you name it i'm
all over it right hasn't said i was
going to pay for it how is going to
Congress to support him but nonetheless
he certainly sounds super of
indispensable and he's going to have to
answer some questions around that he's
shown himself to be pretty articulate on
foreign policy so far quite surprisingly
too many of us on the foreign policy
seen that hadn't seen much from him here
24 Rand Paul on the other side also very
articulate on foreign policy completely
different set of beliefs I mean saying
basically not only would he not have
gone into the war in Iraq but then Iraq
was more stable under Saddam Hussein
something that's clearly true but not a
lot of people want to say and I think
you know a lot of Rand Paul's
inconvenient truths on intervention in
places like Libya sanctions against
Russia cyber surveillance I mean things
that really do seem like they subvert
American values they spend a lot of
money they don't necessarily accomplish
a lot for the Americans clearly
long-term put him much more firmly in
the independent camp so you know what's
interesting again early days but we do
actually see candidates coming out in
very different places in answering these
questions at a very superficial level so
far but I mean with over you know a year
left in the campaign got our campaigns
are long and expensive can we please
stop that but leaving that aside there's
going to be great opportunity to
actually flesh these issues up
you